اذا نتابع معكم ما هذه الصور المباشره من
اضنه التركيه حيث هذا المنزل وما زال عمال
الانقاذ يحاولون اسعاف من بقي على قيد
الحياه تحت هذه الانقاذ نذكر بان العدد
عدد القتلى في هذه
الاحداث او هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
بلغ
1498 قتيلا حتى الان و7,634
جريحا او اصابه في تركيا جراء هذا الزلزال
الذي ضرب اليوم الاراضي التركيه وضرب ايضا
الشمال السوري الارقام غير واضحه في سوريا
ولكن المرصد السوري وفق المرصد السوري قال
بان عدد القتلى وصل الى 900 قتيل مازلنا
نحاول الوصول الى اخر الانباء والتطورات
سواء في تركيا او حتى في سوريا الوضع في
سوريا
بالتاكيد غامض وليس واضحا سواء في المناطق
التي يسيطر عليها النظام السوري او حتى
تلك المناطق التي يسيطر عليها او تسيطر
عليها المعارضه
الدفاع الروسيه تقول
بانشاء مستشفى ميداني بقاعده حميمي
الروسيه بسوريا
لمساعده ضحايا الزلزال ايضا الامم المتحده
قالت بان المساعدات بعيده جدا عن
المنكوبين ما زالت العديد من الاسر
يلتحفون العراء خوفا من هزات ارتداديه
معنى من اسطنبول ايضا الكاتب الصحفي فراس
رضوان اوغلو سيد فراس اهلا بك
تعازينا لكل الضحايا ولكن
ما ممكن تقديمه لتركيا الان هذه نداءات من
الدول من الامم المتحده لكن الوضع يبدو
انه لم يتكشف حتى الان عن حجم تلك الكارثه
نتمنى الشفاء العاجل للجرحى والرحمه لكل
من سقط في هذا الزلزال في سوريا او في
تركيا
طبعا لن تتضح المعالم قبل 24 ساعه اظن ذلك
لضخامه الحادثه
وضخامه الزلزال والهزه الارضيه هناك يعني
يعني قبلك قليل كنت اقرا خبرا في الاخبار
تركيا يقولون يعني خلال تسع ساعات ثلاثه
زلازل وليس واحد وليس هزات ارتداديه يعني
الصباح والظهيره طيب الان فقط اذكر بان
1541 قتيلا ارتفع العدد عدد القتلى جراء
هذه الزلازل تقول ان هناك زلزال ثالث
او هي هزه ارتداديه نعم يعني هذا
دمهم يقولون وفق الافات تقول لا هي ليست
هزار ارتداديه بل هو الزلزال الذي قبل
يعني قبل فتره الذي ضربها يعني شدته يعني
لذلك الكل متخوف حتى المناطق البعيده التي
لم تشعر بالزلزاك واسطنبول وربما المناطق
البحر الاسود الى اخره لكن هناك تحذيرات
حتى لمدينه اسطنبول على الاقل ان تكون
مستعده لاي اهتزازات تصل الى المنطقه
الحادث كبير جدا
القدره الاستيعابيه مبدئيا اظن طبعا لا
تستطيع الان الدوله مباشره ان سيد فراس
ارجو ان تبقى معي بس بعد اذنك ارجو ان
تبقى معي نائب الرئيس التركي الان في حديث
مباشر لنستمع اليه
في ملاطيا وفي هذه المناطق الطرق الطرق
وهناك صعوبات في ايصال المعونات
الى هذه المناطق ويتم استخدام الطرق
البديله
ايضا هناك بعض
الاشكاليات مثل سقوط الصخور في هذه
المنطقه التي تسد الطرق
[موسيقى]
فيما يتعلق
الشبكات التواصل
وايضا ايصال
الطاقه الى هذه المنطقه
وقمنا
بايصال الى اجزاء من المدن
الطاقه
والان
مركز المزداد
مدن بعض الاماكن انقطع الكهرباء مقطعه
عنها ولكن ما عدا هذه المناطق
جميع المدن المنكوبه يتم ايصال الكهرباء
اليها ايضا
في
بعض المولدات الكهرباء يتم طبعا استخدامها
بشكل حذر لكي لا ايضا تؤثر على حرائق
كوارث جديده
وزير التعليم اعلنا ان المدارس ستنقطع عن
الدراسه لغايه 13 من الشباط وسيكون ايضا
مضافات مفتوحه
للمنكوبين كما ايضا صاله الرياضه وايضا
المباني المتعلقه بالتدريس ستكون مفتوحه
للمكيف في الجامعات ايضا
تم اعلان العطله
الاعلان عن استخدام
المباني المتعلقه بالسكن الطلاب
المباني
الرياضيه وما الى ذلك سيتم استخدامها لواء
المنكوبين والمتادير من الزلزال في كوريا
وانطاليا
في هذه المدن
تم ايضا توفير
مباني حكوميه لتوفير فرص
الاقامه
[موسيقى]
المؤقته للمنكوبين
ايضا بالنسبه
اشخاص
نحن
مؤسسات انقاذ محترفه نطلب منهم اخلاء
الاماكن لكي يفيحوا الفرصه
لفرق الانقاذ المحترفه لتعمل بشكل افضل
سنواصل عمليه اجزاء بعض الاماكن المنكوبه
ونحن
نشارك ايضا في هذه العمليه بالتنسيق ايضا
بالنسبه
الخيم والبطانيات والمدفئات الكهربائيه
والمساعدات الاخرى سيتم توفيرها
للمنكوبين ايضا
ايصال المساعدات من باقي المدن التركيه
الى المدن المنكوبه ايضا
نريد ان نعلم المواطنين ان المساعدات اذا
تاخرت في هذا لا يعني انها لن تصل في هذا
الطريق ايضا في موضوع
الغذاء
سيكون هناك
المطابخ المتنقله
التي ستقدم وجبات
الطعام الساخنه
في اشراف او تحت اشراف الهلال الاحمر
التركي
وبالتنسيق منه ايضا
يشارك او ست الوزارات المختلفه في عمليه
توصيل
الغذاء
للاشخاص الذين يحتاجونه
عن ذلك طبعا المساعدات التي تاتي من
الخارج
ثلاثيه من موضوع او الدول التي
ارسلت المساعدات نحن قمنا بتوجيه هذه
المساعدات الى المناطق
المتاثره من اسسات ايضا السدود
من قبل
المياه التركيه واذا ما لحق بها ضرر او او
كان هناك اي خطر تم اعداد تقارير حول هذا
الموضوع
والان حتى الان الامور مستتبه ولا يوجد
هناك اي خطر حول السدود
كل شيء تحت السيطره
ساكتفي بهذا القدر
هناك موضوع اخر
وفي عشر
مدينه مدن طبعا
ممكن ان يتوجهوا اليها بشكل مجاني ممكن ان
يحصلوا على الخبز
وايضا
سنقوم بعمليه التنسيق ايضا اعلن ان الخبز
سيكون بالمجان مره اخرى
اتمنى من الله الرحمه
المتوفين والشفاء العاجل للجرحى
ايضا اريد ان اقول بان نحن في وقت الشده
ان تتكاتف ونظهر
تكافل حقيقه كشعب تركي وبقياده الرئيس
اردوغان قمنا بمواجهه ومجابهه الكثير من
الكوارث الطبيعيه
وهذه الكوارث الطبيعيه كانت كوارث
عملاقه وكبيره
وايضا ضربت البلاد
مره اخرى اريد ان الفت النظر
ان
لا تعتمدوا اي
اي من الارقام التي تصدر عن اي شخص سوى
الارقام التي تصدر عن اداره افاد
وهناك بعض المغرضين الذين يظللون الراي
العام وانتبهوا الى ذلك شكرا جزيلا اذا
كان اي سؤال ممكن ان نجيب عليه
[موسيقى]
الصوت الغير واضح
قليل
تحدثت عن عمليه الازلاء
في
المنطقه التي تحدثنا عنها ايضا
هناك
فتح
للمضافات والفنادق في منطقه انطاليا
وميرسين
وسيتم نقل المنكوبين ايضا الى الجامعات
والمدارس والمضافات والسكان او السكن
الطلاب
ستكون مفتوحه
لخدمه
المواطنين
ونحن ايضا سنشرف على عمليه الاجلاء
فيما يتعلق بالمحروقات والبنزين
ايضا نعمل على عمليه نقل المحروقات الى
هذه المناطق هناك بعض الطرقات التي تضررت
بفعل الزلزال
اذا نكتفي بهذا القدر من المؤتمر الصحفي
لفؤاد اقطاي النائب الرئيس التركيه اذا
انك قالب ارتفاع عدد ضحايا الزلزال الى
قتيل وايضا ارتفاع عدد الضحايا او
الاصابات الى
9733 اصابه قال بانهم يواجهون الصعوبات في
جهود انقاذ ضحايا الزلزال ايضا يحاولون
الوصول الى ضحايا الزلزال في مختلف
المناطق عبره طرق بديره بسبب وتعثر الوصول
اليها
بسبب تشقق هذه الطرق الرئيسه الى تلك
المناطق التي ايضا نقال بان سته مدن من
هذه المناطق انقطعت الكهرباء فيها بينما
بقيت المناطق يتم ايصال الكهرباء اليها
ايضا تحدث بانه سيتم نقل المتضررين من
الزلزال الى مقر اخرى بديله كالجامعات
والمراكز الرياضيه وغيرها معنى ايضا من
اسطنبول الكاتب الصحفي فراس رضوان اوغلو
سيد فراس يعني هذا تحدي كبير
السلطه في في تركيا
لمعالجه هذه الاوضاع اليوم ما الذي هي
بحاجته اليوم من الدول هناك نداء استغاثه
ايضا وجهها من الامم المتحده عود واطرح
هذا السؤال مجددا
نعم يعني انا اظن اولا يعني وصول
المساعدات بسرعه اظن هذا اهم بند يعني
المساعدات قد تصل تباعا وفقه ترتيب الدول
واستعداداتها وكيف سترسل انا اظن كثير من
الدول الصديقه
لتركيا والشقيقه هي سترسل في هذا السياق
لحتى ان اتواصلت لكن لم يتم التفصيل حقيقه
بالتفاصيل ربما بسبب حجم الكارثه حتى قبل
قليل يعني السيد اقطعك ان يتكلم عن
المساعدات الداخليه والخارجيه ستصل الى
مستحقيها وان كان هناك بعض التاخير او
التاخر في هذا صياغه ستصل بسبب يعني ولكن
صعوبه الوصول يعني الان البيت الابيض يقول
بان فرق الانقاذ جاهزه
للذهاب ايضا منظمات الاغاثه المدعومه
امريكيا تعمل في سوريا بعد الزلزال وايضا
فرق الانقاذ من اكثر من بلد
اول جسور الجويه حتى كانت قد بدات او
الاستعداد للذهاب الى تركيا هل هذا كافن
للوصول الى الضحايا
يعني اظن مبدئيا هو مهم جدا لان هذا مرتبط
حتى في وزاره الدفاع التي قالت اذا فتحت
ثلاث ممرات
الجويه ايضا خاصه بها للوصول هذه الطائرات
بسرعه انا اظن السرعه في العمل مهمه جدا
حتى سمعنا ان اول الطلب كان ربما مساعدات
طبيه في في هذا السياق ولذلك هي ربما قد
تصل اولا الامور الاخرى كما تفضل نائب
الرئيس بان البطانيات والطعام والشراب
كلها اظن ستتوفر
بسرعه يعني ليس بهذا الامر حتى الخبز
المجاني الذي تكلم عنه في الولايات العشره
لكن انا اظن ان يعني يجب ان تكون هناك
مسارات متساويه في نفس الوقت ليس فقط
المساله وصول المساعدات تمهيد الطرقات
الطرقات التي ايضا اصيبت في الضرر
لاعادتها بشكل سريع ولو حتى ان تترك فقط
للمساعدات دون استخدامها للعبور السيارات
الاخرى حتى هنا مدينه اسطنبول مدينه الان
اقول لك انها شبه خاليه يعني هذا ليس
واردا عن مدينه اسطنبول بسبب ان اغلب
الناس بسبب العاصفه الثلجيه وربما لم يخرج
ايضا نقطه كل خلف التلفاز لمشاهده ماذا
يحصل الاتصال بالاقارب والى اخره الكل
متاثر في في هذا
الزلزال اظن ايضا التنسيق المعونات وهذا
ايضا ممكن
وايضا مهم جدا في توصيلها بشكل او باخر
حتى انه سمعته يقول عن المساله المناطق
التي لم يصل اليها ربما الطاقه او
الكهرباء ستستخدم بها بعض المولدات
المولدات التي ستستخدم الظن لاضاءه على
المناطق الانقاض ولذلك ستستخدم بحذر شديد
لان اي صوت او موجات الصوتيه هي تؤثر على
اي حركه في الحجار وهو قال الحجار
المتساقطه يعني سواء التي في الابنيه او
الانقاذ او الابنيه التي على وشك السقوط
او التي ممكن تسقط دون ان ندر لذلك هناك
حذر حتى في الاليات الثقيله
الحقيقه انا تعاملت مع الهلال الاحمر
والافاد يعني من فتره بعيده وليس الان
عندهم جاهزيه قويه جدا وكامله بشكل كبير
لكن
الكارثه الان اكبر من هذه الاستعدادات يجب
ان نكون صريحين ولذلك طلبت المساعده من
كثير من الدول ولن تتضح قدره هذه
الاستيعابيه او القدره
للافات وغيرها الا بعد اظن بعد يومين او
ثلاثه لان الكارثه اكبر من القدره
الاستيعابيه نحن نتكلم عن نشر الولايات في
لحظه واحده اظن لذلك طلبت المساعده لا انا
اظن ان غير قادره الان على استيعاب الصدمه
واستيعاب حتى القدره على الانقاذ لذلك
الجيش تدخل الان
والطوارئ وكل ما هو متعلق بالدوله تركيا
لكن
لا اظن انها قادره الان على الاقل لمده 48
ساعه لذلك طلبت فرق انقاذ اخرى ستاتي اظن
من من روسيا حتى من جميع الولايات التركيه
اولا ربما سمعنا ايضا من رو من اذربيجانسه
ياتي لك لكن ليس لدينا تفاصيل اخرى عن
الدول الاخرى
هذه اذا سمحت هذه هذه الصور التي نشاهدها
الان هي من اضنه في تركيا يعني حتى لا
نشاهد الاضاءه الكافيه التي تساعد الطواقم
طواقم الاسعاف تواقم الانقاذ
لمعرفه كيف يزيلون تلك الاحجار والكتل
الخرسانيه عما اذا كان هناك احد تحت هذه
الانقاض ما زال على قيد الحياه الامل ما
زال موجودا
نعم ولذلك تم
الاستعانه وتم ارسالهم من عده مدن منها
كما صرح رئيس بلديه اسطنبول سيارتين فيها
الكلاب المختصه في في هذا الشان هي التي
ايضا ستدخل وتبحث في هذا المضمار قطعت
الطاقه على عده مناطق نعم هذا كما ذكر قبل
قليل نائب الرئيس وهذه ايضا مشكله اخرى
لكن حتى اتصالات يعني انا احاول اتصل مع
بعض ايضا الاتصالات في بعض المناطق ايضا
مقطوعه بالتاكيد لنذهب الى اذا الى
مراسلنا ايضا زيدان زنكلو معنا من اسطنبول
مراسلنا زيدان لنتعرف على تفاصيل الصوره
اكثر واخر تحديثاتها من قبل زيدان تفضل
نعم كما تابعنا مع نائب الرئيس التركي
فؤاد اوكتاي اخر احصائيه لضحايا الضحايا
عدد الضحايا الاحصائيه الحاليه وصلت الى
1541 شخصا قدوا نتيجه الزلزال عدد الجرحى
ارتفع الى
933 شخصا اي ان عدد الضحايا ايضا مرشح
اكثر مرشح للارتفاع اكثر عدد المباني
المدمره ايضا ارتفع بشكل كبير ذكر نائب
الرئيس التركي ان عدد مباني المدمره وصل
الى
مبنى بالتالي نتوقع ايضا جهود اكبر وفرق
هذا يتطلع الفرق انقاذ اكبر في الوصول الى
كل هذه المباني والعالقين تحت الالقاب
طبعا من ضمن ما ذكره نائب الرئيس التركي
ان عدد الضحايا في ولايه هاتاي وصل الى
اشخاص وفي مناطق 106 اشخاص طبعا الحكومه
التركيه تعول من نظرا لبرخامه هذه الكارثه
نتحدث عن مساحه جغرافيه تقريبا المسافه ما
بين ديار بكر وهي ابعد نقطه عن نقطه
الزلزال من جهه الشرق وايضا اضن ابعد نقطه
عن كهرمان مرعش من جهه الغرب المسافه
بينهما اكثر من 500 كيلو متر 10 ولايات
تنتشر في هذه الولايه اضافه الى ولايات
وملاطيا في شمال شرق كهرمان مرعش لذلك
مساحات كبيره وطرق بين هذه الولايات ليست
سالكه بشكل كافي لوصول المساعدات وقواقب
الانقاذ هل هناك طواقم انقاذ لربما وصلت
من خارج تركيا في هذه المساعدات البيت
الابيض كان في خبر العاجل قبل قليل قال
بانه ينسق مع تركيا لتقديم المساعده
اللازمه بعد الزلزال وان فرق الانقاذ
الامريكيه جاهزه للانتشار هل الحكومه
التركيه اعطت هذا الضوء الاخضر
للدخول تلك الفرق سواء من امريكا او من
غيرها
حتى الان الحكومه التركيه لم تعلن عن
تفاصيل الفرق الانقاذ التي تعمل على الارض
طبعا من ضمن المعلومات التي وردت قبل قليل
بدء وصول 17 طائره الى مطاري اضنه وغاز
محمله
بالمساعدات وفرق الانقاذ لكن لم يتم ذكر
مصدر هذه الطائرات هل اتت هذه الطائرات من
الولايات اخرى في تركيا ام اتت من خارج
البلاد لم يتم الحديث حتى الان عن هذا
الموضوع من ضمن المعلومات المذكوره ايضا
ان 3000 جندي من جيش التركي يشاركون في
عمليه الانقاذ وان 13 دوله من الاتحاد
الاوروبي ايضا تستعد لارسال مساعدات الى
تركيا هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه
تحدثت عن ان
اثنان وستون فريقا
62 طريقا فرق الطريق انقاذ من 50 دوله
سيشاركون ايضا في عمليات الانقاذ طبعا
على رغم او كبر بسبب كبر هذه حجم الكارثه
وحاجه البلاد الى مراكز ايواء كبيره
لاستيعاب العدد الكبير من المتضررين اعلنت
تركيا تعطي المدارس حتى الثالث عشر من
فبراير وايضا الجامعات
وايقاف كل الفعاليات الرياضيه والثقافيه
والمسارح ودور الاوبرا تحويلها الى اماكن
اللواء
ارجو ان تبقى معي فقط نذكر بهذه الصور
تصاعد اعمده الدخان في ميناء اسكندرون
نتيجه الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه ايضا هذه
الصور
تاتينا من ميناء اسكندرون الذي يتصاعد
تتصاعد فيه الدخان نشاهد تلك الحاويات
التي سقطت على بعضها بسبب هذا الزلزال
اكثر من زلزال ضرب الاراضي التركيه كما
اشار مراسلنا زيدان زنكلوبيان المسافه
الفاصله بين ديار بكر وايضا
بالنقطه الاخرى اكثر من
1500 كيلو متر تفصل بين ابعد نقطتين
لمكان الزلزال نعود لنشاهد هذه الصور
المباشره من اضنه التركيه في محاوله
لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذ من
انا جئنا تحت هذا الركام قبل قليل لا قال
نائب الرئيس التركي من انهم سيكونوا حذرين
جدا في استعمال
المولدات كي لا تؤثر ربما على الصوت ربما
يسمع من تحت تلك الانقاض
ناجينا يمكن مساعدتهم ويمكن لهذه الفرق
فرق الانقاذ التركيه
لاستخراجهم ما زلنا ننتظر هذه المساعدات
لكل من الفرق في الاتحاد الاوروبي كما ذكر
زيدان قبل قليل او في الولايات المتحده او
حتى الدول التي
حاولت مساعده تركيا
بمد جسور ايغاثه جويه على وجه السرعه
اظهرت صور انهيار حي كامل في سرمدا بادلب
بسبب هذا زلزال مشاهد مروعه نشاهدها
الله اكبر
شارع كامل
ذكر ان النظام والمعارضه غير قادرين على
انقاذ ضحايا الزلزال بسبب العدد الكبير من
الضحايا
العالم
يا جماعه اهو يا الله تسمعيني
مين انت مين
معك حدا
كم واحد معك
ان شاء الله والله ما بعرف شو بدنا نعمل
بعتوا الدفاع المدني
التي تهدمت دون ان تتمكن الفرق الانقاذ من
انقاذهم لان لا يوجد امكانيه للوصول اليهم
في ظل وجود شاهدنا يعني المباني المتدمره
بشكل كامل تركيا دوله كبيره وتنتظر فرق
الاغاثه والسوريه بلد مهدم بلد مدمر بلد
يعيش كان اوضاعا اقتصاديه مزريه لا يوجد
فيه الوقود كهرباء لا يوجد هذا هذا في خبر
عاجل سيد سيد رامي الدبلوماسي اوروبيه
يقول بانه
الفرق الانقاذ او
حتى
المساعدات في سوريا
وهيئات الاغاثه في سوريا تعيد
ترتيب اولويات حاليا بعد الزلزال يعني هل
يساعد ذلك السوريين
يعني تعيد ترتيب اولوياتها يعني نعم
اولياتها بعد اسبوع كم ماذا عن الذين
يموتون خلال هذا الاسبوع خلال الايام يا
سيدي الكريم خلال الساعات القادمه الامر
عندما نقول هناك كارثه انسانيه تحتاج الى
مساعدات عاجله لا تحتاج الى اعاده اولويات
واعاده ترتيب واعاده ترتيب واعاده تاهيل
اي دعم مالي بعد ايام لن يفيد الذين الذين
يصلون مصابين لا يصلون تحت الانقاذ نحن لا
نريد ان نقول لنا بالنهايه نحن تقدمنا
مساعدات انسانيه للشعب السوري واعطينا
القيام كي يبقى من عاش في هذه المنازل
المتصدعه في قيم وماذا عن الضحايا ماذا عن
الذين هم لا يسالون في المشافي ماذا فينا
يزلون في النقاط الطبيه من سيفوزهم هل
سينقل هؤلاء على سبيل المثال من حلب الى
مناطق اخرى هل سيقولون الى داخل الاراضي
التركيه التي تشهد كارثه انسانيه داخل
الاراضي التركيه كان يجب على الاوروبي
وعلى المجتمع الدولي تقديم مشاهدات عاجله
ولا في احد يحدثنا الان عن قانون قيصر وان
قانون قيصر يمنع تقديم المساعدات اذا كان
قانون قيصر يمنع تقديم المساعدات للمدنيين
هذا القانون القانون من المفترض انه
يستهدف النظام السوري ولا الشعب السوري
طيب كيف يتدبر السوريون الان اوضاعهم سواء
في المناطق التي يسيطر عليها النظام او
حتى التي تسيطر عليها المعارضه فرق
الانقاذ هل هي قادره على فعل شيء
كل من يقول حتى لو قالت فرق الانقاذ هي
قادره فهذا الكلام غير صحيح حجم هذا
الزلزال هذه الكارثه الانسانيه الكبيره
اكبر بكثير جدا من امكانيات فرق الارقام
حتى نتحدثنا عن قوه البيضاء في مناطق
المعارضه هي كانت تنقذ الذين يقتلون تحت
مبنى من المباني يتعرض لقصف مرض الطيران
ولكن هي غير قادره باعدادها ان تنقذ
العالقين في تحت انقاذ مئات المباني التي
تهجمت من ارياف اللاذقيه وصولا الى ارياف
حلب الشماليه والشماليه الشرقيه والشماليه
الغربيه بالنسبه لمناطق النصاب النظام
اثبت بانه ايضا غير قادر على التعامل مع
هذه الكارثه الانسانيه الكبيره التي حلت
في مناطق عده من الساحل السوري الى
المنطقه الوسطى الى حلب التي كان لها
النصيب الاكبر من عمليه الدمار وعمليه
الضحايا ارجو ان تبقى معي سيد رامي يعود
الى اسطنبول ومن هناك الكاتب الصحفي فراس
رضوان اوغلو
فراس يعني الجيش الاسرائيلي في خبر عاجل
يعلن ارسال بعثه الى تركيا للمساهمه في
الاغاثه بعد الزلزال هل الان ما زلنا
ننتظر على الاقل وصولها هكذا بعثات ام ام
بالفعل هي في طريقها وفق ما تعلمون
انا اظن يعني هناك بعثات في الطريق او
بعضها قد يكون قد وصل لا يتم تصريحنا اظن
بسبب الاوضاع
الكارثيه وعدم يعني
وعدم ظهور الكثير على الاعلام بسبب انشغال
الكبير على الارض الميدان لكن انا اظن هذا
وارد جدا يعني انا سمعته حتى في الصباح
بعض الطائرات قد تصل او قريبه جدا من
الوصول واظن انها الان قد تكون قد وصلت
على شكل مساعدات سريعه حتى الطواقم ربما
بعض الطواقم ايضا المختصه في هذا السياق
لذلك انا اتوقع ان شيء قد وصل وهذا ما
لمحته من كلام السيد اقطع بالرئيس
واظن شيء والامور قادمه يعني مع الساعات
القادمه لكن عدم الافصاح عنها بسبب ربما
الاولويات التي تهتم بها الان الحكومه
بذلك هو حتى قال قبل قليل بان لا تاخذوا
الاحصائي والتصاريح الا من افات اي انا لا
احد يصارحه الان من الدبلوماسيه او
السياسيين عفوا
نائب الرئيس
وطبعا الافات او ما يسمى بالافات وهي
اللجنه الطوارئ التي هي المعنيه
بالتصريحات لا يوجد تصريحات اخرى اذا
الموضوع واضح ان يعني الاهتمام على ارض
الميدان هو الذي يشغل او يمنع ربما
السياسي لكن احتمال كبير جدا ان يكون وصل
مساعدات الى تركيا ايضا وزير الدفاع
اسرائيلي يوجه بالتجهيز لانشاء مستشفى
ميداني في تركيا بعد الزلزال اذا ايضا نقل
نظام اعلام النظام السوري عن مصدر رسمي ان
دمشق لم تطلب اي جهه من اي جهه المساعده
سواء من نتنياهو بعد الزلزال هذه
التصريحات جاءت بعد ان قال رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو انه اصدر
تعليماته بتقديم الع للمتضررين من الزلزال
في سوريا نقلت صفحه صفحه رئيس وزراء
اسرائيل على فيسبوك عن نتنياهو قوله ان
توجيهاته جاءت بعد تلقي اسرائيل طلبا بذلك
اضاف انه وجه ايضا بارسال فرق بحث وانقاذ
وفرق طبيه الى تركيا بناء على طلب من
حكومه
انقره اذا اذهب الى السيد رامي عبد الرحمن
مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان من
القاهره سيد رامي يعني النظام السوري ينفي
انه طلب المساعده من اسرائيل
وربما قبل قليل نتحدث عن كارثه كبيره لا
يمكن لاحد ان
يستطيع القول بانه يستطيع سد اي ثغره في
هذه الكارثه او حتى انه ليس بحاجه الى
مساعده خارجيه
يعني في تركيا قلت لك اذا تركيا هي تنتصر
المساعدات ما بالك على سوريا البلد
المتهالك المدمر لذلك اقول كان على النظام
السوري منذ الساعات الاولى منذ الدقائق
الاولى للزلزال ان يطلب مساعده الدول
العربيه ان يلجا الى الدول العربيه يلجا
الى العربي الا اذا كان النظام السوري لا
يهتم بحياه المدنيين السوريين لان الامر
كانه لا يعني عندما يقول اللسان بانه
يستطيع تحمل مسؤوليه هذه الكارثه
الانسانيه فهو يجذب حقيقه الامر النظام
السوري ليس لديه امكانيات السوري سابقا لم
يقل هناك زلازل في سوريا يتحملها النظام
لذلك اقول بان على النظام السوري ان يطلب
الان عاجلا وليس اجلا مساعدات من الدول
العربيه الشقيقه مساعدات الدول العربيه
التي تستطيع مد يد العون للشعب السوري
واغاثه ابناء الشعب السوري في هذه الاوقات
الصعبه اذا كانت اسرائيل ترسل المشفى
الاداري الى تركيا ماذا عن السوريين الذين
لا يوجد لديهم مش في مناطق النظام او
مناطق المعارضه تستطيع ان تقوم بطبابط
هؤلاء المصابين نتيجه السلاسل طيب من
يؤمنهم يعني حتى هذاك الدول اعلنت ماده
جسور الاغاثه الى سوريا ولكن كيفيه ايصال
هذه المساعدات يعني في تركيا هناك طرق
بديله في سوريا الوضع ليس كذلك
في سوريا هناك مطار حلب الدولي الذي كانت
تهبط فيه الطائرات الايرانيه التي تحمل
السلاح يجب ان تهبط فيه الان الطاهره
الطائرات التي تحمل اغاثه لابناء الشعب
السوري وين هذه الاماكن وين هذه الاماكن
خلينا يعني نصل الى مرحله بانه نعرف هذه
الاماكن الاكثر تضررا وفق معلوماتكم
ادلب كلها قريبه على مطار حلب الدولي واذا
كان هناك امكانيه للمجتمع الدولي ان يدخل
عن طريق الهوى وان لم يكن هناك امكانيه
فمطار حظر الدولي يستطيع استقبال طائرات
اغاثه من الدول العربيه يجب على النظام ان
يطلب هذه المساعدات فورا وان تدخل هذه
المساعدات الى مناطق حلب ومناطق سيطره
المعارضه ما دون ذلك نحن نتحدث عن استمرار
الكارثه الانسانيه كبيره لابناء الشعب
السوري يعني قلت لك ان تركيا الدوله
الكبير الدوله العلو في الناتو تطلب
مساعدات ومشافي
هو الحاجه الان الى هذه المساعدات
الميدانيه من الدول العربيه الشقيقه التي
التي لديها امكانيات كبيره في عمليات
طيب يعني حجم هذه الكارثه في حلب ريف حلب
ادلب غيرها من المناطق ضعنا ايضا في
تفاصيل الصوره اذا تكرمت سيد رامي
تحدثنا عن نحو 900 ضحيه نتحدث عن مئات
نتحدث عن المدنيين الان هم في الشوارع
حقيقه الامر نتحدث عن اوضاع الطقس
الى هذه المناطق ماذا يفعلون ماذا يفعلون
لانه الان لا يوجد لديهم مكان يذهبوا اليه
نفحوا الى تلك المناطق خوفا من القصف واذا
بها زلازل يعني الان هي يعني تدفع بهم الى
يعني الهجره نحو المجهول الى الشوارع فيها
تلك المناطق التي الان سوف نشاهد او لا
السوريين يلتحفون الطرقات يلتحفون ماذا
يلتحفون القيام الغير موجوده
طيب شكرا جزيلا يا سيد رامي عبد الرحمن ام
مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
[موسيقى]
ابدت واشنطن قلقها ازاء التقارير عن
الزلزال المدمر في تركيا وسوريا وفق
مستشار الامن القوميه الامريكيه فيما اعلن
البيت الابيض ان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
وجه بتقييم خيارات المساعده للمناطق
المنكوبه جراء الزلزال
وفي وقت توقعت فيه الامم المتحده مزيدا من
الضحايا في سوريا جراء الزلزال لا تزال
المساعدات بعيده عن المنكوبين اكان في
مناطق سيطره الحكومه السوريه او المعارضه
المتحدث باسم الدفاع المدني السوري
اسماعيل العبد الله طالب المجتمع الدولي
بتقديم المساعده ومساعده المنكوبين مؤكدا
على انه لا تزال هناك عوائل تحت الانقاض
الزلزال دمر العديد من المباني في مدن
وقرى مختلفه في شمال غرب سوريا فريقنا
استجاب لنداء جميع المواقع المتضرره من
الزلزال لكن ما زالت بعض العوائل الان تحت
الانقاض فريقنا يعمل جاهدا ان ينقذ كل
الناس بكل الامكانيات التي لديه لكننا
فعلا بحاجه للمساعده نحن نحتاج الى ان
يقوم المجتمع الدولي بشيء ما لمساعدتنا
ودعمنا اصبحت منطقه شمال غرب سوريا الان
منطقه منكوبه نحن بحاجه ماسه الى مساعده
الجميع لانقاذ شعبنا
معنى من اسطنبول مراسل العربيه زيدان هل
من جديد هل من انباع عن وصول اي نوع من
فرق الانقاذ سواء الاوروبيه او حتى
الدوليه او العربيه
زيدان
يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال ايضا هذه الصور
مباشره من اضنه التركيه وما زلنا نرى جهود
فرق الانقاذ في محاوله
لمساعده اي من العالقين تحت هذه الانقاذ
اذا
نذهب الى السيد فراس في اسطنبول سيد فراس
يعني الوضع في سوريا اليوم هل ربما تركيا
تستطيع فتح معبر باب الهوى لدخول اي من
المساعدات العربيه الدوليه الى سوريا ام
ان هذا الوضع الكارثي
ربما يواجه صعوبات سياسيه
انا اتمنى اللي يحصل ذلك لا تدخل السياسه
في هذا الوضع لان يعني لا تتحمل المنطقه
والناس هم بحاجه الى المساعده الفوريه
وليس الى الحسابات السياسيه الان انا اظن
يعني ممكن هذا فتحه يعني ان الامور ربما
ليست بهذه الصعوبه تحت السيطره نوعا ما
لكن كيفيه هذا التنسيق وقبل قليل كان
ضيفكم الكريم يتكلم على ان ربما دمشق لم
تطلب حتى الان مساعدات وانها قادره على
الاستيعاب هذا الموضوع هل هذا يعني ان
الغرب ايضا سيقول الدوله السوريه لم تطلب
فلن يكون هناك حاجه الى ذلك يعني حقيقه
الامور ليست جيده حتى التعقيد او الامر
المعقد على الارض الميدان في الشمال
السوري ايضا مختلف لكن انا اظن ان في حال
وصول المساعدات ستصل الى تلك المناطق في
نهايه سيكون هناك تنسيق عبر المنظمات
المنظمات التي يعني مرتبطه فيما بينها
سواء في المناطق التي تحت السيطره
المعارضه السوريه والتي هي ايضا يعني على
تعاون الوثيق مع تركيا لا يوجد حل اخر لكن
المشكله هل يوجد معدات معدات ثقيله معدات
اخرى
للمساعده في رفع الانقاض وما شابه ذلك
يعني تركيا اظن هي تستثمر معداتها هل
سيكون نقل الى تلك المعدات والحقيقه الوضع
صعب لا نعلم كيفيه الوضع الميداني هناك
وان كان واضح انه كارثه هذا ربما يكترث
بشكل كبير الا ربما هذا هو سؤال الساعه
يعني 1500 كيلو ما بين ابعد نقطه والنقطه
التي تقابلها في
التي تضررت جراء الزلزال كيف يمكن تغطيه
كل هذه المنطقه من قبل فرق الانقاذ
التركيه حتى الان يعني بانتظار هذه
المساعدات التي ستصل
لربما يرتفع الرقم او يكون هذا الرقم
للضحايا مرشح للارتفاع اكثر واكثر سيد
فراس
الرقم اظن مرشح للارتفاع
للجانب الطوارئ والمؤسسات المدنيه كلها
يعني تعمل منذ بدايه الكارثه حتى الان
وتوزع لكل جميع المناطق لكن لا اظن ان
عددها يكفي لذلك هي تطلب الزياده في هذه
المساعده كما تفضلت يعني من ديار بكر الى
اظن منطقه اسكندرون التي قبل قليل تفضلت
وقلت عن الحريق الذي نشب في الميناء هناك
وهو يقولون ان هذا الحريق بسبب ماذا ان
الهزه الارضيه حركت او اسقطت بعض
الكونتيونات الموجوده هناك والكونترات
الموجوده هناك فهذا السقوط الذي سبب حريق
واستمر لمده ساعه والاطفاء يقوم بحرف اذن
الهزه قويه اثرت الى تلك المنطقه التي
تبعد اكثر من 1500 كم بينها وبين ديار بكر
حتى
وفق الاف في تركيا تقول ان المركز
المركز الزلزال اي مساحات مساحه مركز
الزلزال قالوا اكثر من سبعه كيلو مترات
فقط لمساحه الزلزال الذي ضرب فاذا كان
المساحه كبيره جدا وهو توزع ايضا على كل
هذه الولايات العشر لذلك انا اظن خلال 48
ساعه لا يمكن ان نقول ان
اللجان الطوارئ والاسعاف والهلال الاحمر
وغيرها قادره على استيعاب هذا الزلزال انا
اظن ذلك ستستعين بالمساعدات والمستشفيات
الميدانيه ايضا التي ستحضر معها
الادويه اللازمه الادويه الاوليه لنقل
التي ايضا طلبتها
دول لم يصرحوا عن تلك الدول التي طلب منها
المساعده ولكن يعني اظن الدول قريبا سوف
ترسل مباشره الى الى حتى بعضها قد يكون
وصل لكن المشكله لا نستطيع ان نتكلم عن
معلومات ما لم تصدرها
الحكومه نفسها
طيب سيد فراس ارجون تبقى معي سنعود
لاستكمال هذا الحديث ولكن الان نتحدث عن
تركيا التي تقع على عده خطوط صدع رئيسه ما
يجعلها منطقه ناشطه للزلازل والهزات
الارضيه نتابع
الهزات الارضيه الظواهر متكرره الحدوث في
تركيا تعود الى وقوع معظم اجزاء تركيا على
الصفيحه الاناضوليه التي تتموضع بين
الصفيحه الاوراسيه التي تمثل نسبيا قشره
غير قابله للحركه والصفيحه العربيه التي
تتجه شمالا بمعدل بوصه واحده تقريبا سنويا
يؤدي هذا الى ضغط تركيا التي تقف على عده
خطوط السطع اكثر خطوط الصدع تدميرا في
تركيا هو خط شمال الاناضول حيث تلتقي
صفيحه الاناضول والاوراسيا هذا ويمتد خط
الصدع شمال الاناضول من جنوب اسطنبول
مباشره على طول الطريق الى شمال شرق تركيا
كذلك يمتد خط صدع شرق الاناضول حوالي 650
كيلو مترا من مرتفعات شرق تركيا الى البحر
المتوسط حيث يتجه جنوبا ويلتقي في النهايه
مع الصدع الكبير الذي يفصل بين الصفائح
الافريقيه والعربيه
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
من اسطنبول معي الكاتب الصحفيه فراس رضوان
اوغلو سيد فراس يعني كما شاهدنا بالتقرير
تركيا ليست يعني جاهله بهذا بهذه
المعلومات ليس اول زلزال يضرب تركيا بهذه
الضخامه في 99 ايضا لربما اليوم عمده
سكاريا ارسل ايضا فرق الانقاذ التي كانت
قبل سنوات تعاني من ذات المشهد ارسلها
لمساعده يعني مناطق اخرى في تركيا
ما الذي يمكن اخذه بالحسبان سواء في
البناء سواء في حتى في هذه الطرق التي
تقطعت السبل بفرق الانقاذ حتى تصل الى
الضحايا لماذا لم تتخذ هذه
الاحتياطات مسبقا هل
بسبب صعوبه او مناطق نائيه نستطيع ان نقول
نقاط ثنائيه لا يعني
هناك قدره كبيره على الوصول الى كل نقطه
في تركيا وايضا تركيا رغم كبرها الكبير
كمساحه لكن يوجد تواصل يعني يوجد تباعد
بين القرى فيما بينها ولا حتى المدن من
الجنوب الى الشمال او من الشرق الى الغرب
هناك تواصل كبير بين القرى يعني ليست
مسافات بعيده تكون خاليه لكن انا اظن عده
مشاكل
حصلت في في هذا الامر النقطه الاولى
يعني نحن راينا الزلازل التي قبلها سنوات
شكلت ما شكلته لكن لم تشكل التصدعات في
الطرقات هذه اظن هذه المره الاكثر التي
نشاهد هذا المشهد ما شاهدناه من قبل
الصداعات الطرقات حتى المدارس مدرج
الطيران في اعطائي او في انطاكيا
تشقق وتكسر بشكل صدعي هذا يعني اول مره
حقيقه يحصل في هذه المنطقه النقطه الثانيه
بشكل عام تضاريس الدوله التركيه بشكل عام
هي ليست تضاريس مستويه كلها يعني
هذه الصور التي تظهر على يسار الشاشه هي
صور
في حلب لصور الضحايا
عبر وكالات الانباء تفضل السيد فراس اكمل
اذا تكرمت
نعم يعني التضاريس هي الصعبه ففي حال ان
يعني تدمر احد الطرق سيتم استخدام الطرق
القديمه او التي غير
معبده في هذا السياق ايضا اظن
تعطل مهمات رجال الانقاذ من الوصول بسرعه
الى الاماكن المراد الوصول اليها
المدربه بشكل كبير التي ارسلت الى كل هذه
المدن لا اعلم حتى اذا هذه الكلاب عددها
يكفي ام لا لعشر المدن وهذا ايضا شيء خطير
النقطه الاخرى التي يتخوف منها هو
الاهتزازات لذلك كالمحركات ربما الحوامات
الطائرات حوامات ربما لا تستطيع ان تنقل
من مكان الى اخر رغم الاحوال الجويه
السيئه التي الحقيقه تضرب البلاد لكن لا
اظن انها قادره على ان تصل الى مناطق
المدمره خوفا من اي
ارتداد صوتي يسقط الحجاره المتراكمه ربما
فوق بعضها حتى يعني
[موسيقى]
قلعت عنتاب التاريخيه القديمه تاثرت في
الزلزال وهدم اجزاء منها الخطوط الجويه
التركيه اعلنت عن اضافه رحلات السفر الى
تلك المناطق من قبل رغم العدم انقطاع
للمساعده لايجاد طرق جهزت خطوط يعني
طائرات وخطوط جويه للوصول في حال استطاعت
المطارات العوده الى العمل لذلك ادعوا ان
يعني الكارثه كبيره جعلت ان رده الفعل
الان غير واضحه للكل يعمل في داخل الميدان
طلبت المساعده الدوليه بكل العالم الطاقه
الاستيعابيه قادره على استيعاب هذه الصدمه
وهذا هذه الكارثه الكبيره
ولذلك انا اظن هذا هو الامر القائم الان
طيب اليوم حينما نتحدث عن كل هذه
المعلومات وكل هذه المساحه الشاسعه في
تركيا نتحدث عن المعدات هل المعدات كافيه
هل المعدات التي جهزت بها قبل هذا الزلزال
فرق الانقاذ هي كافيه من الممكن ام ان
بالتاكيد حجم او عدد الزلازل الذي ضرب
تركيا اليوم اكبر بكثير مما كان متوقعا
سيد فراس
يبدو ان فقدنا السيد فراس ايضا
هذه الصور التي تاتينا من اضنه التركيه
نشاهد فرق الانقاذ في محاوله لانقاذ
الناجين او من تبقى من بقي على قيد الحياه
تحت هذه
الانقاض
كما قال ضيفي قبل قليل قال بانم المنطقه
الواسعه والكبيره تحتاج الى الكثير من
المساعده بالنسبه لفرق الانقاذ سواء
الدوليه او حتى
الاوروبيه او الدوليه يعني رئيس وزراء
اليونان ابلغ اردوغان قبل قليل بالاستعداد
لتقديم مساعده فوريه
لتركيا
اثراء هذا الزلزال لافروف قال بان طبعا
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه قالوا ان روسيا
مستعده المساعده في ازاله اثار الزلزال
المدمر في سوريا
كما نشاهد في هذا الخبر العاجل ضحايا
الزلزال 900 قتيل في سوريا
و1541 قتيلا في تركيا حتى الان طبعا نحن
نتحدث عن رقم تقريبي في سوريا وفق ما اشار
المرصده السوري وليس هناك ارقام دقيقه
لاعداد القتلى في سوريا لكن المرصده شارب
بان كل المناطق التي تقع سواء تحت سيطره
النظام او حتى تحت سيطره المعارضه تعاني
وليس بالامكان
من تقديم المزيده من المساعده وزير الدفاع
الدفاع اسرائيل كان قد وجه بتجهيز لانشاء
مستشفى ميداني في تركيا كما ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اعلن عن ارسال بعثه الى تركيا
المساهمه في الاغاثه بعد هذا الزلزال ما
زلنا ننتظر اخبار رسميه من الحكومه
التركيه او من المصادر التركيه التي تتحدث
عن وصوله ربما فرق الانقاذ الى تركيا
للبدء باعمالها لا نعلم عن عدد هذه الفرق
او متى ستصل لكن هناك حاجه كبيره وماسه
وفقه ما شارى العديد من المسؤولين الاتراك
عن حاجتهم الى المساعده قالوا بان السبل
تتقطع بفرق الانقاذ مما يصعب الوصول الى
الضحايا والمنكوبين الامم المتحده هي
ذاتها قالت بان المساعدات طبعا بعيده عن
المنكوبينه
في تركيا
[موسيقى]
من اربع ساعات
الله
مقطع فيديو في بلده عزمارين في ريف حلب
بسوريا حيث اعتدى تبدو المنازل وقدا سويت
بالارض
وصارت حطاما بفعل الزلزال القوي
ما في مقابله مع العربيه اوضحها المدير
الاقليمي للجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
حسام شرقاوي اوضح ان مدى استعداديه او
استعداد فرق الهلال الاحمر وفرق الانقاذ
في سوريا ضعيفه جدا في ظل غياب جهوزيه
الاليات والمعدات
بعد عشر سنوات حرب في للاسف في سوريا
والمقاطعه وتوابعها
مدى استعداديه الهلال او فرق الانقاذ
ضعيفه جدا اول طلب كان لاليات اليات رفع
وانقاذ
للناس وهذا غير موجود للاسف هو بنحاول
الان اوكي نوصل بعض قطع الغيار وغيره
وغيره فمهم جدا طبعا نوصل للناس للناس
الموجودين تحت الانقاذ
ونكمل البحث
والانقاذ والاسعاف الاولي مهم جدا برضو
نركز على عشرات الالاف الان بلا ماوى مياه
بلا اكل
حسام شرقاوي اضاف ان الوضع الامنيه في
سوريا يعيقوا عمليه وصول المساعدات وفرق
الانقاذ الى المناطق المتضرره جراء
الزلزال كتير دول قامت والطائرات تتحرك
والقافله تتحرك خاصه من الدول المجاوره
وعلى خلال ساعات الدعم وصل خاصه من الدول
المجاوره
توصيل الدعم داخل سوريا طبعا له في صعوبات
انه نوصل داخل سوريا كون المطار وضعه
ماساوي
ونوصل الدعم للمناطق المنكوبه خاصه انه
العاصفه الثلجيه اللي صار لها كذا يوم
الان مستمره تعيق
توصيل الدعم وبرضو الوضع الامني
احمد مظهر سعد الصحفي من غازي عنتاب ينضم
الينا الان سيد احمد ما هو الوضع لديك في
غازي عنتاب
كل التحيه لكم وللمشاهدين جميعا الوضع
بالتاكيد ما زال وضع الماساويا منذ الصباح
الباكر وحتى الان هناك محاولات وحثيثه من
اجل انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه تحت الركام وما
زال هناك الكثير ممن تهدمت فوق رؤوسهم
وفوق اجسادهم لا يستطيع احد اخراجهم
لاسباب لها علاقه بالامكانيات ايضا صحيح
ان الدوله التركيه مجهزه في كثير من
القضايا التي لها علاقه بعمليات الكوارث
والانقاذ لكن بالتاكيد الذي حدثه هو اكبر
بكثير من حجم اي دوله وامكانيات اي دوله
ومن ثم فان تجد ان هناك
مثلا الى ضخم كبير خدم فوق رؤوس الساكنين
لا يمكن ببساطه يعني انتشال الجثث او
الاحياء الذين يحاصرون
الركام من بهذه البساطه وبهذه السرعه هناك
يحتاج جهود كبيره جدا وامكانيات كبيره جدا
والمساعدات الخارجيه حتى الان خجوله ولن
تاتي بعد طيب
ابدا اولا بالوضع البيداني فرق الانقاذ ما
هو وضعها كيف تعمل خاصه في حلول الظلام في
تركيا
يعني هو بالاساس جرت عده تجارب خلال
الاشهر الماضيه على الزلازل والكوارث في
تركيا وكان متوقع ان هناك كوارث وزلازل
فلذلك هناك استعداد تاكيد وهناك امكانيات
ما للانجاز لكن كما قلت قبل قليل المشكله
هي في هذا الكم الكبير لم يكن احد يتوقع
هذا الحجم الكارثي الكبير الذي حصل عشر
ولايات تركيا
انصابها الزلزال ما عدا طبعا الشمال
السوري بقضيه وقضيته ايضا اصيب بهذا
الزلزال ومن ثم فان اي امكانيات ستكون
قليله مقابل هذا الكم الهائل الذي حصل
بثواني خلال دقائق اصبح الناس تحت الركام
ثم اتت قضايا فيما بعد هي الارتدادات
الهزات الارتداديه وهي خطيره للغايه وقد
حصلت هزه في الساعه الواحده ونصف بتوقيت
تركيا هذه الهزه كانت حقيقه عنها علميا
انها ليست فقط ارتداديه بل هزه اخرى جديده
كانت اقل منها التي حدثت صباحا بقليل
بمعنى انها ايضا خطيره وهذه تؤدي الى
انهيارات يعني عندما يكون هناك بنيان
متشقق ومعظم البناء في عين ترى اصبح
متشققا فتاتي الهزه الارتداديه تخلخل هذا
التشقق وتؤدي لانهيارات كبرى وهذه اخطر من
من التي حصلت في البدايه خاصه اذا كانت
طويله كما حصل في الساعه الواحده والنصف
في توقيت تركيا وكانت مخيفه جدا وتجد
الناس مذعورين يهربون من اذيتهم باتجاه
الشارع لا يلون على شيء لا يعرفون اين
يذهبون وحقيقه هي حاله من الخوف والزعر لم
تشهد تركيا ولا سوريا مثل خلال قرن طيب من
خرجوا من بيوتهم من
تهدمت بيوتهم
ونجوا اين ذهبوا الان
هلا هناك تم فتح صالات الافراح
وصاله التعذيب والمراكز الثقافيه
وايضا الجوامع من اجل استقبال هؤلاء الناس
وفعلا تم استقبالهم وهناك معظم هؤلاء
الناس يتجمعون حتى اللحظه في هذه المساجد
والاماكن والصلاه والى اخره لانه
بالجلوس في الشارع وقد وقفوا الشرع فترات
طويله في الساحات لا يمكن في ظل وجود ثلج
ومطر ينهمر فوق روسيا وبرد تحت الصفر
وبالتالي حاله صعبه جدا هناك اطفال لذلك
كان لابد من
احتوائهم في هذه الاماكن وحاليا هم
متواجدين كما قلت في هذه الاماكن التي
تذكرت وبالتالي حاله صعبه جدا لا يجرؤون
على العوده الى منازلهم المتشققه حتى لو
لم تكن مهدمات التشقق بحد ذاته بشكل خطرا
كبيرا على الناس عندما يريدون لانه كمان
ايضا هناك من يتحدث اليوم عن ان هناك هل
ذات ارتداديه جديده ستاتي بعد ساعه او بعد
ساعتين او ثلاثه او هكذا يعني هناك تنبؤات
حول ذلك ومن ثم هذه الهزاش الاعتداديه كما
قلت مخيفه لانها تؤتي اكلها عندما تاتي
على بناء متشقق وبالتالي يمكن ان يكون
هناك حاله حزن وهذا خطير جدا في ظل وجود
الاف الناس المتكدسين في هذه البنيات
وطبعا السوريين لهم النصيب الاكبر بكل اسف
يعني من هذه الحصه في الجنوب التركي لانه
كما نعلم الذين هجروا من سوريا الى تركيا
معظمهم سوريين سكنوا في الولايات الجنوبيه
انطاكي غازي عنتاب كهرمان مرعش اورفا هذه
المناطق هي والريحانيه وهي تغسلها حقيقه
بالسوريين وايضا بالاتراك لكن المصيبه
الاكبر كانت السوريين في الجنوب التركي
وايضا في الشمال في مكانين كانت في
المصيبه كبيره جدا والكارثه اكبر سيد احمد
احمد مظهر سعد الصحفي من غازي عنتاب ارجو
ان تبقى مع عيسى وعودي اليك لاستكمال هذا
الحوار اذا تكرمت
اذا هذه صور مباشره من اضنه التركيه
ايضا فرق الانقاذ التي تواصلوا عملها مع
حلول الظلام في تركيا وقبل قليل كنا نتحدث
من
المولدات التي تحدث عنها نائب رئيس الرئيس
الرئيس التركي فؤاد اقطاي قال بانها ستعمل
وفقا معايير محدده حتى لا تؤثر على اجواء
العمل لفرق الانقاذ او تصعب من معمتهم كما
ننوه الى ان سته من المدن
التي انقطعت عنها الكهرباء بينما باقي
المدن يتم العمل لايصال الكهرباء اليها
وفق ما قاله فؤاد اخطائي نائب الرئيس
التركي
وزير الداخليه تركيا سليمان سويلو اقاله
من جهته انه تم تعبئته جميع فرق الانقاذ
مشيرا الى ان قوه الزلزال بلغت 7.4 درجه
وهي درجه مدمره
قوه زلزال بدرجه 7.4 مدمره بشكل خطير
ونقوم بارسال قوات الدرك والشرطه والقوات
المسلحه التركيه وفرق الطوارئ والكوارث
والهلال الاحمر التركي وفرق البحث
والانقاذ من جميع انحاء البلاد الى
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
وصلنا
يبقى معنا احمد مظهر سعد الصحفي من غازي
عنتاب لكن الان اذهب الى
اسطنبول ومن هناك فراس رضوان اوغلو الكاتب
الصحابي سيد فراس يعني هذه الخرجه
الخارجيه الفرنسيه تقول بانها سترسل
مجموعتين للبحث والانقاذ لكن الانباء حتى
الان عن وصول اي من هذه الفرق الى تركيا
كما اشار ضيفي قبل قليل من غازي عنتاب
الوضع يعني يبدو انه
متازم جدا
نعم الحقيقه الوضع يعني ليس
ليس جيد للامور حقيقه كلها في
يعني الحاله الجويه والحاله الارضيه كلهما
يعني تضافرت مع بعضهما
هذه الكارثه ولذلك انا اظن ان
يعني حتى الان كل هذه الجهود التي تقوم
بها الرسائل المؤسسات الطوارئ ومؤسسات
الحكومه حقيقه بغرض واضح في هذا السياق
ولذلك انا اظن ان المساعدات القادمه
ستحتاجها تركيا لكن هو سباق مع الزمن متى
تستطيع ان تنقذ عدد اكبر من الارواح وكيف
ستستطيع هذا حقيقه تحتاجه لذلك قبل قليل
عن ان بعض الدول قررت ارسال المساعدات
ومشافي ميدانيه في هذا السياق لذلك انا
اظن ان يعني خلال 24 ساعه ربما ستتضح اكثر
المساعدات القادمه
يعني حتى في بعض المدن المستشفيات تضررت
ولم يعد لديها طاقه استعابيه لاستقبال
الجرحى
وفق بعض الانباء نعم هذا صحيح
صحيح
مستشفيات في عده هذه المدن نعم بعضها خارج
عن الخدمه بعضها طبعا ليس العدد كبير ولكن
بعض المستشفيات في
مستشفى كبير قديم نعم تضرر جزء كبير من
هذا جزء منها لا يمكن استخدامه ولذلك
المستشفيات الميدانيه هي الحاجه الاولى
وذلك لو تذكر معي قلنا في البدايه ان اول
ما طلبته تركيا ربما هي المساعدات الطبيه
الاولى وربما المشفى الميداني هو احد هذه
الافرع من مساله الامور العلاجيه
والدوائيه في في هذا السياق الى اي مدام
الى اي مدى هذه الحاله الجويه التي تمر
بها تركيا قد تؤثر سلبا على حتى انشاء هذه
المستشفيات او حتى الى وصول فرق الانقاذ
ولربما استمرار عملها حتى صباح يوم غد على
الاقل
لا انا لا اظن ان المستشفيات الميدانيه
يعني تتاثر او لن تحصل او لن تنصب هذه
المستشفيات بسبب الاحوال الجويه في تركيا
ربما يمكن ذلك هناك يعني مناطق متعدده حتى
اذا شاهدتم في احد المشاهد تم وضع يعني
مثل الشوادر وشيء يغطي في بعض المناطق
للاستكشاف او استخراج المتضررين او
المحصورين او تحت الانقاذ انا اظن
مهيئه لهذا الامر لذلك لا بد من انشائها
بكل الولايات وهذا
هل سيكون تركيا مع دول اخرى ام سيكون هناك
دول اخرى لديها الخاصه هذا التنسيق حتى
الان ننتظر افاقنا ستقول به
نتعرف على الوضع في غازي عنتاب على سبيل
المثال مع السيد احمد مظهر سعده الصحفي من
هناك سيد احمد يعني هل الطواقم الطبيه
كافيه هل
من مستشفى الميدانيه بدا العمل به في غازي
عنتاب
التواصل الطبيه تعمل بكل ما تستطيع من قوه
وامكانك لكن كما قلت قبل قليل هناك حاله
غير مسبوقه هناك اعداد غير محسوبين بهذا
الشكل هناك كارثه حصلت
واتت خلال الساعه او اقل فاصبح على الجميع
ان يتحرك في هذا الاتجاه ويصعد وينقز والى
اخره وهذه مساله ليست سهله على الاطلاق
لذلك ان لم يكن هناك مساعدات في الموضوع
الطبي والصحي من الخارج وبشكل جدي وعملي
وميداني فلن يكون هناك احتمالات جديه
لانقاذ هؤلاء الناس لا يكفي الاعتماد فقط
على التواخم التركيه الموجوده في عنتاب
لابد من مساعده اخرى وقد اتت من حتى
الولايات اخرى مساعدات طبيه وصحيه بيوميا
كانت تاتي وخاصه هذه بهذه المناسبه اتت
باعداد كبيره من اجل المساعده والمساهمه
ولكن مع ذلك القضيه ليست سهله وخاصه في
موضوع الانقاذ في موضوع التقديم في موضوع
يعني ان يكون مشفى مكتظا وفي نفس الان هو
معرض من خلال الهزات الاعتداديه لاخراج
المرضى منه وهذا ما حصل عندما حصلت الهزه
الابتداديه الكبرى في الساعه الواحده
والنصف ظهرا كيف وجدنا المشاكل يخرجون
المرضى منها الى الخارج حفاظ على
الارواحهم خشيه من ان تكون هناك اجزاك
اكبر وبالتالي تؤدي الانهيارات في مبنى
المشهد القضيه يعني حقيقه مربكه ومتعبه
وتحتاج الى طواقم كبيره وامكانيات ضخمه
واعتقد ان تبكي لديها كل ذلك لكن لا يكفي
لمصيبه ولكارثه بحجم كارثه الزلزاليه التي
حصلت صباح هذا اليوم والتي ما زالت ديولها
متنافره في الشارع في الابنيه وفي السكن
كل لحظه وكل شاني حتى هذه اللحظه الناس لا
تجرا العوده الى منازلها حتى هذه اللحظه
يعتقدون ان هناك اجزاء اعتياديه الليل
وهذا ما اشد هل هل تم تحذير من ذلك بشكل
رسمي
تم تحذير وايضا بنفس الان الناس تتابع
لوحدها ما تصدره بيانات الافاد
الطوارئ التركيه وبالتالي هي تعرف لا احد
الان الا يعرف ويتابع لانه احفظه على روحي
وعلى نفسه وبالتالي اي كلمه اي جمله تصدر
او البيان ياخذه الناس ويتلاخفونها
وبالتالي يتعاملون معه بشكل جدي وقد حصل
ما حصل خلال فترات سابقه عندما تم التنبيه
وحصل ان هناك هزات ارتداديه وان هناك
مسائل تؤدي الى خطوره حقيقيه على حيوات
الناس حقيقه في جنوب الترك خاصه وفي هذه
الولايات التي تعرضت الى ماساه الحجه
الارضيه صباح اليوم وبالتالي فان اي
معلومه جديده سوف تعطي اكلها وسوف تنتشر
مباشره بين الناس لان الناس تتلقى في ذلك
وليس لها همد اليوم الا
احساس الزلزال وتطوراته وتنبؤاته ارجو ان
تبقى معي سيد احمد مظهر وكذلك سيد فراس من
اسطنبول ارجو ان تتفضل بالبقائه معي ساعود
لاستكمال هذا الحوار ولكن اذهب
لاقرا الخبر التالي اوضح وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انتوني بلينكن ان واشنطن تقيم
خيارات الاستجابه الشامله للزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا واكد في بيان ان
بلاده ستبذل كل ما في وسعها لمساعده
المتضررين خلال الفتره المقبله نضيفا نواش
على اتصال وثيق مع انقره وشركائها في
المجال الانساني لتحديد ما تحتاجه المنطقه
في الايام القادمه بلينكن اشار الى ان
جهود الاستجابه الاوليه في تركيا جاريه
بالفعل مؤكدا ان المنظمات الانسانيه
المدعومه من واشنطن في سوريا تستجيب لاثار
الزلازل في جميع انحاء
البلاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا اذهب الى اسطنبول اولا ومعي من هناك
الكاتب الصحفي فرس رضوان اوغلو سيد فراس
يعني كما قال ضيف في السيد احمد مظهر من
غازي عنتاب بانه
الناس متخوفه من العوده الى منازلها بسبب
الخوف من الهزات الارتداديه التي قد تحدث
او لربما لبعض المنازل المتصدعه وبالتالي
الخوف من سقوطها هل استوعب الشارع في
تركيا الصدمه ام ان ما زال الوضع في حاله
انكار في حاله صدمه وذهول حتى الان
نعم اسمح لي ان استخدم تعبيرك يعني انكار
وصدمه وذهول في كل الشارع التركي في هذا
هذا في هذا الصدد الكل متفاجئ ويعني ربما
يعني الزلزال ضرب المدينه او مدينه او
مدينه اخرى هذا كان يعني ربما اكثر ما كان
يخاف منه فما بالك في عشر مدن في صدمه
كبيره قبل قليلة تذكر مدينه اسطنبول
خاليه تقريبا يعني لا يوجد هذا الازدحام
المعروف عنها وهي مدينه يعني يسكنها اكثر
من 16 17 مليون ساكن ويدخلها خمسه ملايين
يوميا ويخرجها منها اليوم تقريبا فارغه لا
يوجد احد الكل ربما يترقب الكل يجلس
ويتابع الكربما يريد السفر الى الجنوب
الذين من الجنوب او من مناطق الزلازل هل
يستطيعون ذلك
الطرقات مغلقه يعني انا سمعت انا كثير
منهم وصل الى انقره مثلا
واسكي شهير وبعض المناطق اخرى لكن لم
يستطيع القدوم اكثر باتجاه المدن المنكوبه
وهذا يعني انا بسبب الطرقات سينتظرون يعني
خصوصا الذين لديهم اهاليب لديهم اقرباء
لديهم ربما سقوط لقتله او جرحى
نظرنا احدا يعني سيبقى منتظرا هنا وهذا
ايضا من المساوئ التي ستزيد اعباء على
المؤسسه المنظمات التي تقوم
بالاجلاء المنكوبين طيب سيدي احمد مظهر
يعني قبل ان اسالك
بالاوضاع حاليا اخر اخر التطورات هل من
ارقام
محدثه في غازي عنتاب
هل هناك بصيص امل من انه قد يعود الناس
الى الى بيوتهم ام سيستقرون في المقرات في
المقرات او المقر التي خصصها التي خصتها
الحكومه لهم او خصصتها الحكومه لهم
حسب الاحصائيات عديده الشهداء او الضحايا
في عنتاب برحلها 80 شخصا على الاقل هذا
وفق احصائيات الاخيره لكن الاعتقادي ان
الناس ما زالوا خائفين وبالتالي لا اعتقد
انه الليله على الاقل سيذهبون الى بيوتهم
انا الان اشاهد في احد المساجد كيف يتجمع
الاسر والعائلات وكلهم لا احد يقول ساعود
الان يعني كلهم يتحدثون عن الغده وبعد
الغد لان الحقيقه المساله ليست سهله عندما
يحدث هذا الزلزال المخيف والمرعب والذي
قال فتره زمنيه ولا لاول مره بهذا الشكل
وحصل ما حصل وتهدمت ابنيه لا اعتقد ان
الناس سيخاطرون لانفسهم ويذهبون قبل ان
يطمئنوا تماما على انه لا هزات ارتداديه
ولا خطر على ارواحهم وارواح اطفالهم
ونسائهم وبالتالي
نعتقد انه ما زال الخطر قائم وما زال
التخوف موجود لدى الناس كل الناس في
الجنوب التركي سواء كانوا اتاثرين لانه
الوضع ليس فعلا على الاطلاق وما عاش ومن
عاش حاله
البلدان بقوته التي حصلت يدرك تماما ماذا
يعني الخوف من الزلازل ويدرك تماما ماذا
يعني الحفاظ على ارواح اسرته وبالتالي لا
احد سيخاطب اليوم باعتقاد هذه الليله على
الاقل بالعوده الى منازله
الابنيه من حولي كثيره فارغه لا يوجد فيها
احد الناس لا يجرؤون على الصعور الا
للدارات القصوى
ينزلون وبالتالي هم سينامون بالتاكيد في
الاماكن التي تخصصتها الدوله والبلديه لهم
من اجل ان يكونوا اكثر امانا حتى في هذه
الاماكن هناك من يتحدث عن امكانيه الخروج
الشارع اذا ما حصلت هزات ارتياديه لانه
كمان يخاف من الناس حتى في الاماكن التي
لا تقف واحد او هي ام مهيئه لهذه الحالات
يخافون ايضا من حالات انهيارات قد لا تحمل
عقوها شكرا جزيلا
للكاتب الصحفي احمد مظهر سعدو من غازي
عنتابه شكر موصول للصحفي فراس رضوان اوغلو
من اسطنبول اذن قلوبنا دائما مع اهالي
الضحايا مع الضحايا ونتمنى
بسرعه انقاذ من هم تحت الانقاض
اذا المواقع الاثريه في سوريا كان لها
نصيبها ايضا من الدمار نتيجه الزلزال
المديريه العامه للاثار والمتاحه في سوريا
افادت بتعرض قلعه حلب لاضرار طفيفه
ومتوسطه منها سقوط اجزاء من الطاحونه
العثمانيه اجزاء كبيره من قبه مناره
الجامعه الايوبي وتضرر مداخل القلعه ومنها
مدخل البرج الدفاعي المملوكي وتعرضت واجهه
التكيه العثمانيه لاضرار
في محافظه حماه تضررت بعض المباني داخل
قلعه المرقب الاثريه في مدينه بانياس
وسقوط اجزاء من حجاره الجدران وكتله من
برج
دائري
تحت المطر
هتخوف
ما كنت فيني اعبر قديه كان في خوف كانت
ليله رعب خوف الايفين انه تقلب البنايه
عليهم وما في مين يطلع فيهم يعني لانه
اكثريتهم فالين اصحاب الاملاك بيجي اخر
الشهر وبيقبض بس عنا ما هيدا العامل
المعطر اذا قشطت البنايه امبارح فوق منه
بدك تتفرج تفرج هايدي ما في ترميم بالنبعه
قعدت طلعتك لعمار في شيء عم يبرم بالبيت
عرفنا انه هزه ارضيه عملت هالاولاد وطلعت
بنص الطريق كل شي اطفال ومن عمر 3 سنين
وانت طالع نيم بالطريق مبارح لهلا اذا
بتحب تروح تشوف العالم كلها نايمه من ورا
هالليله امبارح ليله كتير كانت صعبه على
العالم